a threat to the country and its energy
sector is how state electricity workers
are describing a deal to sell 40 percent
of a state-owned 300 megawatt power
plant in sri lanka
hundreds of employees have demonstrated
outside the headquarters of the ceylon
electricity board
on 21st september the government and an
american company promoted by the u.s
ambassador in colombo announced reaching
a sales agreement it covered the
purchase of this power plant
construction of a gas storage terminal
and a monopoly of gas supplies to all
plants using liquefied natural gas
this deal is not good for the
organization see be not good for the
country because it's a it's an enormous
loss for the country and also this is
the first time that we see that that
unsolicited proposal being entertained
by the government when an ongoing tender
is in progress unions want the deals
scrapped and say they will ensure this
is done
on tuesday union representatives filed a
petition at the supreme courts
challenging the deal
award attended to any country through an
open process in keeping with accepted
international norms if sri lanka doesn't
have the money but be transparent
unions say there has been no
transparency about the deal with even
cabinet ministers still unaware of its
details one and a half months later
this was made clear when 11 governing
alliance partners made scathing remarks
against those behind the deal
there was no discussion at all don't lie
it was brought surreptitiously by force
we will not tolerate and watch these
things happen we will not accept it
ignoring our conscience just to hold on
to ministerial posts people of this
country did not give president kotabaya
japaksa the mandate and trust them for
someone to steal that power
tilaksiyambalapitya has worked in the
energy sector for more than 35 years
we asked him about the implications of
the deal
i would ask everybody to exercise
extreme caution extreme caution one
because this was as the media says it is
an unsolicited proposal
we should also not forget that the
electricity act the law in the country
says electricity should be procured on a
competitive basis
electricity should be procured on a
competitive basis so therefore that
means the fuel should be procured on a
competitive basis siem bella peter says
the take or pay terms where sri lanka is
locked into accepting a fixed amount of
gas regardless of how much it needs is
not good and even dangerous
sri lankans are hoping it's not too late
to ensure the deal is in the country's
best interests
but more pressing is avoiding power
outages that may plunge the country into
darkness
fernandez al-jazeera colombo